is this lifestyle you know the fancy
sexy clothes and and glamorizing
yourself and putting your ass out there
on the street is it like something that
a lot of young girls are like appeal you
appeals to them it's a like a yeah cuz
it's a it's a statement it shows that I
can do whatever I want when I want it's
like a sense of self-control and freedom
like I feel more comfortable naked than
I do in regular clothes and that's
because I I feel secure in who I am and
a lot of women that don't feel secure
within themselves they don't they they
have a lot of issues with themselves you
like your body you like your oh yeah
your whole
yes all right
honey honey uh where you from originally
where did you grow up um Sacramento
California Sacramento and tell me about
your family you um so my family is is
complicated we're well Blended I should
say um it's like three separate sides
it's my biological parents side my fost
family side and my adopted family side
so you're adopted at what age um like 4
and a half by my aunt what was going on
with your parents that they lost you so
um in Louisiana my mom went
outside and I was sleepwalking as a
child so so I went outside looking for
her didn't know that I could lock the
door and I was walking the streets the
neighbors um heard me they started
throwing rocks that me CU I thought I
was a cat and they end up calling the
police when they realized that I was a
child and then the police ended up
searching our house and they found like
crack behind the toilet so they ended up
um placing me in FAS care immediately
with no release to my parents at all
whatsoever unless they went through a
2-year like drug treatment program
program wow yeah and my and the court
order was my dad would have to be a
single dad in order to keep his rights
to me but he wanted um to still be with
my birth mom so he signed his rights
over to my aunt which then later had to
take around she had to take um adoption
courses for me to be adopted from
Louisiana to
California how would you describe your
childhood in general um
I wouldn't say it was easygoing because
like it was it had it ups and downs it
was hard like seeing my parent my
biological parents come in out of come
in and out of my life and I had no
understanding as as to why I couldn't be
with them um my adopted mom couldn't
really like help me through my emotions
with it cuz she didn't really like she
kind of understood but she just always
put it as Oh They'll be back later so
like I don't understand why you're
you're were
upset um so I don't know I kind of grew
with like a little bit of emotional
neglect yeah like early childood I kind
of felt that I felt unheard and unseen
so I kind of grew up thinking as if I
continue life without being heard or
seen I won't have no
problems but no no abuse yeah most
definitely not child abuse though but
like in my relationships yeah for sure
abuse um my yeah
my last boyfriend um in
202 to 2021 he was really abusive I was
with him for like almost a year nine
months how long have you been doing this
kind of work two years now two years
since since the um the the exact day
will be um October 10th in 2 years oh
yeah coming up yeah so let's go back to
the beginning how you got into this you
went to high school you graduated uh
yeah I graduated high school with a um
college credits in photography really
yeah I had a I had a 2.5 3.0 grade
average in high school how old are you
now I'm 22 22 mhm how did you get
introduced to doing this kind of work so
um when I left my boyfriend in Atlanta
Georgia the one who is abusing him yeah
I got him arrested and he stole my phone
and my wallet with all my ID and
identification and everything and I told
my parents to uh my my aunt actually to
cancel my plane ticket back to
California cuz I wanted to stay I wanted
to make it work in Georgia because I
felt like I was giving up too easily and
I met this girl she was doing it and we
ended up doing a double date together
and then I left California got two jobs
realized that that wasn't really working
out like how am I only making about $600
$900 a month for two jobs when I made
500 and literally an hour so I was like
if I can continue to make 500 every hour
for a week straight I would have a lot
of [__] money you figured out that
this is fast money yeah fast money easy
money as long as you know how to stack
it and save it and do the right things
with it invest in it where it needs to
be invested it works for you are you
doing this with a a business manager no
no pimp no I do the solo
Doo by
myself yeah do you have a drug problem
no absolutely not no drugs um I'm a
pothead and I barely even
drink so what are you doing you're
making good money I assume yeah um
mainly because I'm pretty I just know
where to place myself in like the right
people at the right times and just make
it work for me a lot of girls are
jealous of me because I can outwork them
and it's true how much money do you make
a typical day um anywhere between to
like a minimum a, 1,500 or like 2,000 if
I really push myself 2,000 a day yeah
that's a lot yeah it's a lot but it
comes
easy comes really easy cuz more
people majority of my dates double than
what they actually are so if it's 100 I
get 200 sometimes 300 4 150 180 see
that's what I was just telling the girl
I just interviewed before you it seems
like all the girls whether they're
pretty ugly short fat tall skinny
whatever it doesn't matter it seems like
everybody's going asking for 100 bucks
cuz that's what it's the Trap that's
what gets him through the door because
that's the lowest price it's but then
but then the reality of it is a girl
like you can get yeah the reality is is
oh [__] $100 only got me 5 to 10 minutes
now you're pretty and I didn't finish
now I want more time but you want more
money and I don't want to make you mad
so what I'm going to do instead is open
my wallet you said how much for how much
extra time here you go that's how you do
it and I throw fits I'm a temper tantrum
I'm like a little baby I get mad I my
entire like I've been told my entire
attitude my demeanor changes I'm like
yeah because like you think I'm only
worth $100 and I get and I get my and
like my last three dates were just like
for 200 and up you think I want $100
from you no I want more than that you
can at least do
150 you have a lot of regulars I assume
I do a few um uh yeah I do I'm not going
to expose them like that because they
know who they are do do you get no no I
don't want to expose anybody do you get
uh guys who take a liking to you and
become a little more attached oh yeah um
I've had boyfriend proposals I've never
had a marriage proposal before and and I
will feel bad if the guy that does ask
me to marry him cuz I'm going to be like
uh you want I'm like okay we can get
married but I need about $775,000 and a
divorce contract within the next 5
months after the marriage cuz no you're
a
hustler because no you you you think
you're addicted to this fast money now
it's like a it's like this is my drug
money is my drug if I if I don't have if
I don't have money or my weed I have an
attitude because now I feel like I don't
I don't feel like myself no more so in
two years of doing this you're a
pro oh yeah do you travel mhm I've
traveled to Florida Colorado Louisiana
Texas
Nevada yeah I've gone back to Florida
twice
though and Louisiana multiple times like
Louisiana is probably shout out to New
Orleans cuz that's that's my favorite
City you heard me it's my favorite City
my favorite state um if y'all know me
out there it's
honey it's me still in
C I'm like a legend on Bourbon Street I
my name is legendary like bartenders
know me bouncers know me restaurants
know me like whenever I go anywhere they
know it's money you have a very likable
Personality yeah I've had God I've been
asked to um help like promote like a
club a few times but I'm like no because
that would be volunteer work you guys
are just going to pay me an alcohol and
why why why would I get drunk on a job
when I can just you know ask somebody to
give me free drinks when they're going
to give me money anyway how did you
become so business savvy um at such a
young age yeah so in my childhood I
started off as uh Girl Scouts I did Girl
Scouts for a few years and we sold Girl
Scout cookies and if you know anything
about Girl Scouts the more cookies you
sell the more rewards that you
that your troops can get and because me
my mom and sister were always top
sellers we've always gotten be able to
do more we've gotten our troop um funded
for cruises three times we've gotten
laptops cameras yeah all we knew all we
when it came down to selling cookies you
you couldn't out sell us you couldn't
cuz we had people already lined up we
had people at my mom's job willing to
buy cases not like one box but like
three cases of cookies to give out for
Christmas we had teachers who wanted
their own little cases
yeah making money is in your blood mhm
it really is it really is my dad said
that uh till the see my dad died saying
that he was broke come to find out he
had like over $100,000 in his bank
account yeah we like money getting to
the money and collecting it and saving
it that's just all that's all I know how
to do and you figured out a very mhm
easy way to make F yeah like my first
little hustle was B was dog sitting I
didn't babysit I didn't I didn't care
for babies at a young age until I had my
son I was 19 when I had him and you have
a son mhm he's 3 years old now three
years old and are you raising him um
co-parent me and his dad
co-parent yeah we're pretty good at that
but yeah my first hustle was like dog
sitting and I would charge my brother
like $7 $7 a
week to watch his dog
and uh I got like maybe about like cuz I
was young I was being stupid I was like
20 $28 out of the entire month for four
for $7 a week yeah and then that turned
into high school when I started selling
um cookies and chips for like a125 a bag
and then by the end of the week I had
like 200 I had like $200 in my pocket
off of my
students like off of my peers but yeah
that's all I that's all I know how to do
it's just it's sell anything make
money and you figured out the ultimate
thing to sell now yeah the ultimate
thing to sell is not vagina it's time
you don't sell [__] ladies you sell
time there's the difference prostitutes
sell
[__] I sell time time is valuable
exactly cuz at the end of the day time
can't be can't be replaced money can be
replaced but my hour my 20 minutes my 15
minutes no it can't be replaced so I'm
need to be compensated for every minute
of that time what have you learned about
men from doing this kind of
work men are simple-minded creatures
that's the always answer they are really
simple if you think about it you can
throw up you can throw a pretty woman in
his face and like he'll forget that he
had work the next hour like they're
really simple if they have a boner they
lose all brain power they don't know how
to think no more but also they're lonely
they're like
men that honestly pay for sex or pay for
company or anything like that they are
the truly loneliest and sometimes it
don't even be because they're lonely so
I can't say all of them it just be
because they just have money and they
know that the more money they have they
can have um a collection and options at
the prettiest girls all over the world
but men that do this are truly they're
truly lonely at heart because you can
see it in their eyes like they'll even
talk to you after and the little things
that they say like it's like oh like
they're try to like laugh off of what
they just did but it's like damn I
really just did this because I couldn't
get a girlfriend like I just spent 150
200 on a girl that's that just gave me
20 minutes and I couldn't go to the mall
and speak to a girl for
free like it's a shortcut they find it
easier this way because they feel like
it's less they don't have to chase they
don't have to sell a drink to anybody
that's not going to really buy it you
know just
just you think you're selling the
ultimate commodity oh yeah I'm selling
I'm selling a fantasy for sure like I I
know I'm a fantasy cuz there's no
especially in on figa I'm a fantasy I'm
lightskinned I'm pretty I can talk well
I look nice I always smell nice and I I
have a lot of clients and because I have
a lot of clients those clients talk to
other clients and they will bring them
specifically to me
so yeah you you haven't had anything bad
happen to you yeah I have um I have been
raped I've been robbed three times yeah
been raped one time in Sacramento
horrible experience never again never
never never never date men and vans with
dreadlocks what do you think of Figaro
Street Figaro is dangerous is really
dangerous um I would say I would say
Figaroa and and the one in Seattle and
the one in Seattle they they compete for
the most dangerous um tracks in the
world for sure for sure because there's
like guns and things like that not only
that because a lot of girls go missing
and unfortunately they go missing on
Figaroa they do and sometimes they be in
people's basement sometimes they're tied
up in hotel rooms like a lot like there
was a girl was just killed in her condo
downtown LA and she was doing this and
we don't they don't know who killed her
and then there was another girl found
dead on the Magic Carpet end right by
the 105 um West entrance on fig she was
found dead in there there was a girl
stabbed on 101 by metrop
PCS um there was a shooting on 10 there
was a shooting on 104 yeah there was
it's a lot it's really dangerous this
this doesn't make you reconsider your
career choice it doesn't it doesn't
because at the end of the day I accepted
what came my career choice I accepted
the danger it's either I play around the
danger or the danger play with me you're
addicted of it all for sure it's like
the danger the fast money the excitement
the it's like a f fashion show for a lot
of you girls so that's the thing that
it's a fashion show to them they don't I
see this as my everyday life like at the
end of the day like I I pray I thank God
when I go out I thank God when I come
back home and I'm safe and I and I made
my money safely I use all my condoms I
don't do anything crazy I don't do
anything bare like nothing like that so
I pray I I thank God every every day I
step out I step outside I pray like you
know protect me send me your angels and
then when I go in when I go inside I
tell him thank you for protecting me
because even though I'm choosing to sin
even though as a child of even though I
am your child you're not going to let
anything specifically hurt me like and I
know know that for a
fact have you had any siblings or any
family members that are in the game yeah
I have brothers and I also have um
sisters as
well yeah my we we as of right now the
siblings we don't talk at all we haven't
spoken a word to each other in months
your brothers are pimps
yes do your parents know what you're
doing yes they do yeah what do they
think of it my birth mom she uh she
knows that she knows what um why I'm
traveling for she knows she'll be like
well there's no money in Sacramento so I
don't blame you for leaving my dad
before he passed away he told me don't
ever pay no man if you're going to do
this don't ever pay no man because all
they're going to do is take your money
and they can leave you high and dry and
that's
true I've been through that
unfortunately and it's terrible it's
terrible think you're one of the
smartest girls on fig I've I've
interviewed yeah figure it out my uh my
adopted mom just tells me to text her
when I'm outside and text her when I'm
inside just so she knows that I made it
in for the
night yeah but as of right now we don't
have a good relationship at all yeah
parents don't like this kind of
stuff not even that she doesn't like it
it's just that she's just the she's
contradicting herself and I don't like
that because like how you can how can
you say one thing about somebody else
but at the end of the day I'm not ask no
one's even asking you to um for money
for their bills or anything like that
like how can you downplay how can you
downplay my hustle when at the end of
day I hustle harder than you and that's
facts like you can work at 9 to5 I
worked a 9o5 anybody can get a 9o5 but
can you say that you can survive can you
survive you know gunshots you know the
police can you say that can you say that
you can survive being being robbed like
and getting your money back back like
you
know like no one can say that you work
every day yeah you work 7 days a week
seven days a week every day you work
days or nights or both both that's how
I'm able to like make about 15 to $2,000
every
day because I'm I I work Non-Stop and
there's a specific street that I'm
always on that's like my corner and like
nobody can make corner like nobody can
make money when I'm there on my corner
and you say you're saving your money mhm
yeah my next goal is to get um my
apartment and then a new car cuz my car
was crashed by my baby daddy and uh he
uh never got it fixed so you've been in
love before yeah never
again yeah the last time I was in love
made me pack a duffel bag and a backpack
and fly to
Georgia
and then I said [__] love I love myself
to never put myself through that again
cuz no that's crazy and he was crazy do
you think prostitution should be
legalized I
do I think prostitution should be
legalized but I also do think that sex
trafficking should be highly illegal cuz
there's a difference there's a big
difference way big difference and sad
thing about it is that sex trafficking
is more legal than prostitution because
at the end of the day we keep the money
that's the problem the government keeps
sex trafficking money they don't tell
they don't they don't say that
though let's think about it if there's
300,000 kids go missing every year in in
the foster care Department okay where do
they go Jeff Jeff Jeff's um Island
Records hasn't even been released yet so
where do all those kids go because I do
know for a fact there's a lot of money
in kids a lot there's a lot of under
girls out there exactly there's a lot of
money in kids and that's because that's
a that's it's sick that's a pedophile
type of thing and that's like a certain
type of fetish for them because like
they want something that's that's
vulnerable they don't want someone like
me who can say no who can tell you when
you're wrong and who can and who can
speak up and and fight back they want
someone they can't fight back that can't
say no and doesn't know right from wrong
I interviewed a 13-year-old girl the
other day 13 and she's a pro like you
are she travels without a pimp crazy
13 I wouldn't say that she doesn't have
one cuz I feel like that she do I feel
like she doesn't want to say anything on
camera that could have been the case
yeah yeah she didn't want to say
anything on camera because she knows she
knows that if she said anything like
that he's going to he's going to federal
prison like not not County but Federal
for a long time too for a long time
because she most definitely has one
because I know I I don't I'm not going
to say them I don't say I know them
personally but I know that there's men
out there that intentionally put young
girls on the street because they because
they're runaways they don't want to they
don't want to stay home listen to Mom
and Dad me neither I hate listen to my
mom I I didn't run away but I didn't
come home till like midnight because I
knew she left for work at 2:00 in the
morning so I wanted to I wanted to come
back when she wasn't there but these
girls that you know were saying are
trafficked sometimes they that they want
this life they can't say that they want
this life because who the [__] how you
can't even you can't even grab graduate
high school no mama how can you say you
want this life when you don't even know
how you can't even complete step exactly
you haven't you haven't even completed
Middle School no it's like they're
brainwashed is what I'm saying so like
how can you say that you want something
you haven't even done anything that you
wanted to do for example I wanted to
graduate middle school so I did it I
could have stopped immediately I could
have dropped out I wanted to I wanted to
graduate high school I mean she comes
from a broken home and that that that's
the core of it all exactly cuz I think
well I I can't really say that because I
do know that there's girls that come
from stable homes and that's and they
still want to do this because they're
like I grew up sheltered is it is this
life style you know the the the fancy
sexy clothes and and glamorizing
yourself and putting your ass out there
on the street is it like a like a
something that a lot of young girls are
like appeal you appeals to them it's a
like a yeah cuz it's it's a statement it
shows that I can do whatever I want when
I want it's like a sense of self-control
and freedom like I feel more comfortable
naked than I do in regular clothes and
that's because I I feel secure in who I
am and a lot of women that don't feel
secure within themselves they don't they
they have a lot of issues with
themselves you like your body you like
your yeah your whole yeah flaws stars
and
all I love it I love myself I never
trade it for anybody no matter what I
do nope do you have any regrets in your
young
life um yeah I
do I regret believing
[Laughter]
pimps that's my biggest regret because
if I didn't if I didn't believe in my
first one I wouldn't be here right now
where would you
be oh my God to be honest I'll probably
be in Drake's lap right now I would have
been kissing Drake
that's probably where I would have been
no actually reality I probably would
have been like you know like on the the
northern side of La like the east side
towards Hollywood type of area not not
working no was definitely not I could
work yeah I would have already invested
my money into me modeling so that way my
modeling I could have like started my
modeling career by now and then you know
let that tick off from there like I
could have been cover a
Vogue so you prefer working the street
rather than hotels or the internet um no
I do all of it it's just the streets
picks up faster than hotels bars and the
internet you can make that money quick
yeah because on the internet you're
competing with pictures versus in the
streets you see exactly you see what you
want is isn't there a lot of like Faker
a lot of BS on the internet oh yeah I've
been played before a few times on the
internet the guys don't show up the
girls real guys don't show up I've been
told that I've had dates I've had dates
almost cancelled on me until they've
actually seen my face because they were
like they were like you're way they're
like whoa your pictures are way too
gorgeous and um I didn't want you to I
didn't I didn't know if you were going
to be ugly or not so I almost cancel it
on you that's why I didn't want to send
you my address until like an hour later
until you FaceTime me like I've actually
had someone tell me that another girl
used my ad pict pictures for herself she
us your pictures yes and when she showed
up to the guy's house he uh kicked her
out
immediately that's funny and I couldn't
really do anything about it because well
she already like she took my pictures
like anybody can screenshot and like you
know edit and do all type of [__] when
you're on the street do you use your
intuition with these guys that approach
you oh yeah I I don't know what it is
it's like it's like a it's like a sensor
in my stomach I'd be like oh yeah
there's one coming and this one's for me
and then it's usually end up being more
than what it than what it is you trusted
me you don't know who these guys are you
know some of them are serial killers
some of them are oh yeah no I can send
to Jeffrey I can send to Jeffrey dmer
for sure I can send to Jeffrey
dmer what's your favorite kind of trick
um a rich
one um my fa no no I'm serious though a
rich one because they have they they
have no complaints they have no problem
spending they have no problem spending
extra because to them it's Chum change
like they don't they don't see you as an
object they see you as like sort of like
an investment piece in a way because
they want to see you again it's like
what you're doing is almost like therapy
right yeah I give them therapy and I
give myself therapy by collecting my
shopping money and give myself retail
therapy everyone's making themselves
feel better yeah and I'm I in a way I
feel good I I I feel happy I feel a
sense of wholesomeness when I make them
feel good but what scares me regarding
the legalizing prostitution thing is
like if if
they you know stopped somehow stopped
everything that was going on with you
girls on fig where would all these these
guys what would all these guys be
doing it's scary to think that would be
the worst part that'd be scary right
though so I I have a theory is um you
have a lot more rapists out there oh my
God
no no I think that's when sex
trafficking comes in that's when you go
to the sketchy like hotels and brothel
where you see the girls lined up and you
see a guy with his hand out and they
walk by and you pick one and that that's
the scary thing about it is now you're
not now you're turning to you're turning
to actual victims like you're not
turning to to to someone that that's
conicting yeah yeah that's that's the
scary thing about it yeah people people
look at prostitution they think oh we
should ban this no I think it would
create a bigger monster yeah it would
create a bigger monster and because
prostitution and sex Trant has such like
a a very thin blurred line they're
easily they could easily be mistaken as
one or the other or or
both like for say if you do if you do
have a pimp that's in a way that can be
considered you know pandering or sex
trafficking for a Pimp Pimping Pimping
and pandering that would be that that's
that's what that would considered be
because now you're not doing it for
yourself you're doing it because you
have someone in the back of your head
telling you what to do otherwise if you
don't do it you know what's going to
happen to you type of
[__] what do you think the most Mis
understood thing is about girls that do
this kind of work they want
to is that they want to you don't think
you don't think the girls want this no I
don't I don't think you talk about it in
a positive light like cuz I want to do I
mean because I've seen the positive of
it like i' I'm getting to that point to
where where I don't I won't be on the
streets no more I can I can see that I
can see myself being in a hotel room all
day just hello hi you want to come see
me like but yeah I truly think that if
you like if you want to do it you have
to do it with a smile you have to be
happy about what you do like if you want
if you can you because you can say oh I
want to do this but you're only doing it
for the money and then you realize that
when you when it's a slow day for you
and you haven't really made anything
like how like now like now what are you
doing it for like are you sure you still
want to do this because no any it takes
it all it takes is one bad day and
you're tired and you're everything is
gone everything your life everything
everything can be gone in a Flash so if
like I don't know I feel like for me if
like I because I want to do this I take
it so serious like very very serious how
how do you think it's changed you um it
made me more business savvy not even
just because in not even in the streets
but in general I have given my clients
business advice that actually worked for
them because they were like well how
would you do this when they they would
ask me how how do I attract masses and I
say you have to become the mass that you
want to attract if you want to be a if
you want a lot you have to be a
lot you're a lot and I get a
lot honey what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
22 years my 20 like all of my 22 years
oh yeah like what what what's the most
important lesson that you've learned in
your life never giving
up never giving
up never because if you the moment you
give up that is the moment that you quit
on life but what's your what's your
dream down the road 5 years 10 years
what do you want to be 5 years down the
road I'm going to have um I'm going to
have my own businesses businesses nail
salons hair salons eyelashes Studios all
all of it you'll be out of the game I'll
be no I'll still be in it I'll just I
just won't be on the streets and if I am
on the streets it's because I just want
to flex like how far I came in life and
how far Y'all [__] was talking [__]
about
me I want to show y'all that like yeah I
may have a nappy wig but my Mercedes
Benz is not
nappy all right honey thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you
apprciate lots of luck out there hope
you're safe oh yeah and if y'all want to
follow me it's the real honey with t
ha yeah
excellent thank you
Don